[Musique]
pour nous c'est du patrimoine alors ça
une valeur parce qu'il faut se
représenter le boulot que les gens ont
eu à extraire ces pierres à creuser le
sol pour former ses terrasses à agencer
c'est pierre donc déjà mayall respect de
ce travail qu'ils ont fait qu'ils ont
bien fait de nous dans nos valeurs
associatives il ya le respect de
l'architecturé traditionnelle
donc ça veut dire aussi le respect du
savoir faire
[Musique]
c'étaient les terrasses les murs les
terrasses et des vignes sur ce versant
sur lequel on est aujourd'hui là c'était
plutôt des vergers mais il n'y avait pas
un arbre qui poussait
dans ses collines s'était rasé
complètement et parce que c'était une
exploitation en hausse de 7 et
l'hydratation vivrières il fallait que
les gens produisent donc c'était pas du
tout de la forêt un mur comme ça ça peut
aboutir 150 200 ans mais il faut que ce
soit bien fait au départ donc mais la
technique en elle même moi je ne
maîtrise pas je me suis que c'est un
chantier école donc voilà je vais fait
partie des écoliers de l'école
[Musique]
la théorie est relativement facile pinte
contre pente fruits c'est souvent des
termes peu technique mais qui sont très
faciles à appréhender ce qui est plus
long c'est trouver la bonne pierre pour
le moment droit alors ça c'est de temps
en temps c'est horrible on peut mettre
plus d'une heure pour trouver une pierre
ces départs naturels on est leur taille
pas ou vraiment très très peu juste si
haïti juste un petit angle a cassé mais
sinon les retail pas d'où la longueur
enfin le tarn corner pour un trouver
des gamins je sais pas plus mal dorsaz
on trouve ça chouette ça redonne vie en
fait on raconte l'histoire et et puis
après dans leur montage
je sais pas pourquoi j'aime bien j'aime
bien faire ça
il ya les oiseaux et à l'air et à le
soleil ont failli à la pluie mais on est
dans la nature
et on oublie tout parce qu'on est
vraiment obligé d'être concentré sur ce
qu'on fait ça fait vraiment du bien
[Musique]